there's some confusion whenever new
rules to control the spread of
coronavirus are introduced
i want to clear up some of that
confusion today
i was very saddened to see this
particular exchange on social media this
morning
from a supermarket telling a woman she
could not buy period products
this is simply wrong it's an
incorrect reading of both the
regulations and the guidance
i'm very sorry this woman was given this
information supermarkets are open
and trading as are many other shops
and are able to sell the wide range of
everyday items that we all
need but there are some other items
that won't be on sale for the next two
weeks
these are items that other high street
shops which are currently closed
can't sell at the moment
we face a very real public health
emergency in wales we have a two-week
period
in which we need to do everything we can
to break the cycle of transmission
and do everything that we can together
to bring coronavirus
under control infections
occur and are spread when people are in
close contact with other people
in homes in pubs in shops
we've listened carefully to what people
have been saying
so we will take action today so that
retailers understand
that our rules already allow people in
acute need to buy the basics
which are essential to them over the
next two
weeks but we also ask people to
understand the very real crisis
that we are facing at the moment in
wales and to please treat people
working in our shops with the respect
that they deserve we're meeting
retailers this afternoon to review the
regulations and guidance
to make sure that it is being applied
fairly and
consistently if there are anomalies we
will look
at whether the guidance need to be
revised or strengthened
to make it clear that supermarkets have
some discretion
to sell to people who are in genuine
need